you took on such a big role when you all
decided to relaunch ebony magazine which
we are all grateful for for me to touch
it um and be able to bring this to our
community in a way that they deserve man
like it's not even a job michelle it
really is a journey that i feel
that god has assigned me to and now
we're celebrating you one year as ceo i
don't know do we call it a birthday do
we call it an anniversary man we call it
a glory
hallelujah the world really is
celebrating not me but this opportunity
to bring this narrative back to life
what do you kids think about mama being
the boss lady oh yo i'm not the boss i'm
the uber i'm the car i'm the i'm the oh
of all kind of things so what i hope
they learn from my journey is this is
that i pray i praise but i put in the
work michelle
something her kids are sure to admire
ebony's commemorative print issue beauty
and brains coming out february 11th the
first print issue in three years honors
and uplifts black women in stem fields
so we teamed up with michelle and olay
for this exclusive first look at their
collab when we announced to our queens
10 of them right that olay was going to
give them 10
000
a piece you know that's life-changing
we're giving people an opportunity we're
exposing them to black scientists you're
really highlighting the need for women
of color in these stem fields it's one
of the fights that i have in the
marketplace how can you know me how can
you advertise to me how can you build
products for me if there's not
representation at the table so olay
kudos to you for understanding
one of these products is olay's facial
moisturizer from their new shea butter
line
i'm gonna be 56 right i like i say that
proudly and i carry this little jar
because this olay
shea butter
is the truth it's the joint as my
grandmother one of the reasons why i
love it is because it doesn't make your
skin feel oily it makes it feel
it's just like so much moisture in it
and listen target is my store you can
get the product you can get the magazine
at target or target.com there you go you
can pick up your ebony issue and you can
pick up your shea butter ola facial
moisturizer at target i'm gonna see
y'all there